you know Mike the world is a very
complicated place but not for long
because this segment is called nice nice
[Music]
[Applause]
nice Marco Rubio lil Marco put his big
boy lifts with his shoes and really
stood up for me in the hearing that kid
can handle his water not nice John
McCain he tried to defend me but he has
incoherent unrelated question and didn't
know what he was talking about that's my
move McCain what's next you're going to
crash a beauty pageant dressing room I
did that I told people I did that then
they told people I did that I did it
nice me after the terror attack in
London last weekend I offered words of
comfort and support and even a bit of
constructive criticism
not nice London's Mayor Sadiq Khan who
criticized me and said I should stay
away from England I'm always getting
attacked by guys named Khan you got this
guy you got that other Khan guy last
summer but I'm going to beat them both
there's an art to taking down a con
believe me
I know because I'm a professional con
artists
[Applause]
when your son raises millions of dollars
for kids with cancer not nice
Forbes reporting that we transferred a
hundred grand out of that charity and
into our business
oops but still those kids made a wish
and it got granted they got to hang out
with Eric Trump he hides the money in
his gums Bugsy right up there you can
sit up there yeah I'm gonna switch it up
my switch it up lift it up your radius
wait I'm ready to switch switch it up
not nice worth the wait Isis Hillary
created them and I will destroy them in
30 days or less or your pizzas free
gobble not nice I ran a country so
backward so devious that they won't even
tell us they're actually a modern open
society where many Americans would feel
completely comfortable that's the
dirtiest trick of all that's cool oh
nice Isis attacked Iran I can't believe
it
if the enemy of my enemy is my friend
does that mean they're both my friends
now I think so I think those are the
rules sir oh okay I got it
NATO's my enemy and Isis and Iran
my friend nice Sara Huckabee Sanders my
spokeswoman today she told everyone I'm
definitely not a liar
she did a great job and I would have
used her earlier if I respected women
boobies I don't I don't respect women
not nice
her father Mike Huckabee the Internet's
worst comedian look at this sweet Rachel
Maddow tonight reveals Amelia Earhart
and Jimmy Hoffa are found they are
married and had a child Snoop Dogg who
paid no taxes ever what the hell is he
talking about a better joke yeah ha ha
ha ha ha she's a pilot is he he didn't
have a jackal to fly someday don't say
nobody pays taxes not like losing his
love